welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz and today
I'm in a nother we work brand new we
work and I'm joined by Rhys Warren who
is a team lead for few and far and heads
up the software engineering team don't
worry I'm good man
yeah so when set the scene as I said
we're in Waterloo then do we work they
have a skate ramp sounds they're fully
functioning skate run yeah now they have
a fully functioning skate ramp
downstairs that Rhys Conley told me that
and you know allowed to use no no we
were allowed to use it on the first week
and we weren't allowed to use the
basketball hoop which everyone's really
confused by so rather than let us use a
basketball hoop but they've now shut
down the skate ramp but it's still fully
functioning yeah but no one is allowed
on it's just a bit weird it's like what
is so stupid yeah is really stupid and
it's just a vicious it's awful we could
put so many different things that are
like what can we do that's really cool
and edgy yeah yes it's crap yeah like so
true and course alert as I was saying
reach we're always like to start
how did Rhys Warren entered the world of
recruitment my friend how did that
happen so I was I studied at King's I
studied there Kings studied philosophy
of all things where there is no obvious
career path into anything and I was
looking through Guardian jobs and indeed
and all this stuff and I don't remember
applying for recruitment that's actually
not I don't remember whatsoever and I
applied for a wreck to wreck like a open
day essentially where did like a group
interview and I went in with eight other
interviewees
and everyone was suited and booted and I
was in this baggy Primark horrible shirt
and basically they just SPECT me outside
the recruitment businesses and I was
going to all these interviews and one of
the most thrown out off actually and I
was thinking this really isn't going
well and then ya came across engineering
I did more research into it because my
background is in any sports and it
looked really really geeky and techie
and I was like damn this actually looks
quite sure
and the rest is history as I say okay
cool so so how did you stumble across
the engineering piece then so that's
like that's under the tech yeah industry
right yeah so originally I was applying
for lots of different types of
recruitment there was property
recruitment there was FMCG there was
looking remember half of the stuff and
then when I eventually went into
interview with the current company you
know when you're like on the bus journey
to the interview I should probably do
some research product in engineering
about what the hell is that
and then yeah looked into it and have a
chat with with the guys here oh yeah we
basically build apps I was like that's
really oh yeah yeah and that was it what
was your perception of equipment this
point so when I went further my rhetoric
into you they set out the scene of
recruitment of everything that it could
be and there was a dude who kept talking
about how many Porsches he owned and he
flashed his Rolex at me oh my god and he
said that he has three houses ones on
the south of France and two other ones
okay and I was sat there and I was
thinking this guy is such an absolute
tosser unbelievable how arrogant this
dude is and I don't know if he listens
like with hilarious if he does he'll
know exactly who he is and he was
explaining was that look know most
recruiters are hated and he was he's
quite honest about it as well because
like that's what we paid so much Wow and
I didn't really mind that I don't mind
the idea of being haters I love well
that's fine I don't care
and yeah the more Easter didn't dip into
it and again what I see with these guys
they set out so clearly like you're
going to hate this you know they kind of
made me want to do it more yeah it was
like I'm not gonna hate yes and because
I just didn't believe because everyone's
saying it's horrible what's this it's
like it can't be that bad like there's
no way you could weep and the more I
looked into it I saw negative reviews
and stuff I was like well I don't think
I'm I'm gonna be that bad at it I should
I maybe I can not make a change that
sounds really cringe but maybe I can
just do a slightly better job yeah I'm
carbonation stuff I calmly
and how that was what so then just two
and set the sort of tenancy you've been
a few and fun and for three and a half
years right yeah yeah and that's been
your only recruitment job yeah yeah so
these types of conversations on what
recruitment is and these lots of things
only sort of ring a bit years ago
laughing I just think that's lame like I
say if you like knowing what you know
now
yeah just out of interest before we sort
of move into how things went and stuff
like how how would you sell recruitment
now but if we if the like the next Reese
was in front of you right now yes
sitting on the other side of the table
and you knowing what you know now how
would you how do you sell it to him I
would probably do what we was done
originally but probably worse I would
say that it is really horrible at first
because I think when you first do this
job getting used to the hours and the
unev work you put in the amount of
rejections and for me personally I'm
terrified on a night out turn to
approach a girl right in case she's like
no you're ugly a little break Mike
honestly it will break me yeah and at
first it's kind of like that when you're
you're calling through job boards you
like well I've actually got a really
good role and they're like no please
don't call me again or where did you get
this number
it's just it was awful but the longer
you do it the more you enjoy it so I'd
repeat what we said the only thing I
would really change is more information
on the market I think it's really
important for everyone to understand the
market they're getting to because I
think the type of recruitment that you
do really depends on you're all really
effectual experience of recruitment
because I imagine recruiting for people
in finance it's very different from
recruiting people in in software
engineering yeah and I would hate
finance because yeah yeah yeah okay
that's interesting so you touched on
that a bit there always like to speak to
people about their sort of fashion
recruitment because I had my own
experience with that and how difficult
it was yeah how were your first five
months then to be honest they they were
really really strange so when I first
run the business we were about eight or
nine people do so much more than we are
now
and we were in a position where the
engineering team though
three of us not including mobile and I
was working for this guy who was
hilarious and we'd come into the office
and we would just sit and chat and just
basically not do much work it was it was
it was pretty great to be honest with
you there weren't as many pressures as
there are now to like pay the bills I
wasn't in a we work now with the rent is
ridiculous and it was just it was good
at first for the first six months or so
I came in and I was just so determined
to make some money because I just moved
into a flat where my rent was a grand a
month a while on a 20k base and I I
wanted to go somewhere cheaper but I was
going to fighting like Mile End I'm Alex
in Clapham and they were like just holes
in the bathroom I can't do that so I go
somewhere posh so I was just constantly
on it trying to do as much as possible
and then after those those six or seven
months the team left okay and I was left
on my own which was quite bizarre
because we went from this culture where
we would really bounce off each other
and rip into each other or whatever and
it was a really nice that balanced
environment to essentially just just me
in the the web engineering side so the
guy in and mobile thankfully state which
was nicer there was two of us
technically unlike the dev side yeah
well I had to take care of all the
account management all the 360 piece
everything after seven months and and
after that to be honest with you it was
it was a bit horrible mom because that's
when it all falls on onto you to deliver
against everything and what was your
voice of what was you doing before that
point was you just focusing on sourcing
yeah yeah so it was literally just
working with other people's clients
their relationships of people's jobs
yeah exactly so we were working a
Council of the world so at that time we
had a huge account in Thailand okay and
we were just drilling Seavey's and yeah
yeah and I think we did like 20
placements which I was really focusing
on delivery yeah definitely and then to
take of the wider responsibilities I
loved account management it's great
really enjoyable but to do across all of
the remit so that was every language you
could basically think of right you're
covering it so I was like a generalist
engineering recruiter so to do all of
that and the account management and then
to take care of like a qualification
calls etc it was just a bit
and at the time are we got our initial
progression plans so so wrong
so I got promoted from being a sorcerer
to you know like a senior sorcerer and
then I had to go and start pulling my
own clients but pulling my own clients
whilst doing all of this stuff as well
was almost impossible because I'd also
had no experience doing BD before and
like I said I am a huge [ __ ] so the
idea being rejected by a client I was
just a heartbroken by so I said no no
we're not using agencies let's like say
yeah it was very very bizarre after that
but okay so so and up to the 12 month
mark were just on your own yet did you
okay cool yeah I spray that down a bit I
think there's some interesting points
there so just so and also just to help
the people listening so you'll market
tech very saturated I mean there's so
many tetra crews out there right digital
we're gonna call it because it's a very
fruitful yeah
financially rewarding from a real
equipment perspective yeah market right
so those first six seven months how how
did you get to know and understand the
market firstly just out of interest like
how did you get to another tech market
and yeah and get to understanding
software engineers how do you go about
that the the first and most obvious
technique is to ask yeah you can debate
um when people come into my team now
they were so scared of seeming stupid
things out there I find it really quite
bizarre the the best recruiters I've
ever met are always the ones which
pretend to be stupid
so they'll speak to the candidate and
say oh so I have interest like how did
the rest api's work that doesn't make
you stupid
not knowing here we aren't supposed to
know that I don't have a degree in
income so I'm no freaking idea right
yeah so going in with that mindset of
saying oh I saw this on your CV that for
example you've done a migration over to
a microservices architecture what the
hell is that
yeah that'll make me shoot because I
don't know that but if I get those
answers that I need you can essentially
not repeat it to future candidates
without processing it but
you have a starting point to then do
your own additional research and I think
in this market specifically if you don't
know your stuff when it comes to
technology and this is more on the palm
side contractor thinks more about a
process rather than the market but if
you don't on the palm side you're just
going to look like an idiot and you
can't do client qualifications properly
because you've done all they're looking
for and you can't be kind of a kind of a
qualifications because you don't
understand if they're any good because
you can't call them out and be like well
you've just said that you did this how
does that work because I didn't think
that was possible
hmm and then you go and you can just
sift through the you know the worse
engineers I guess okay so um so did it
come with quite an actual Qi then to not
feel stupid when you was asking them and
now like I said within my degree I
studied the the subject of tables for a
year right whether or not tables existed
I'll live even joking I paid 9 grand to
study tables so at that point I'm not
worried about asking questions which
seems stupid because because I've met
someone who is on forty five grand a
year to teach a module on whether or not
tables exist I'm not worried about that
anything all right so the advice then
for people that can be and that can be
applied to any market right yeah that's
when you early on I think I definitely
had to I mean I worked in insurance and
recruiting and insurance so that helped
but I think yeah is a real common
challenge for people because no one
likes to feel stupid so I think yeah and
what I'd also say from my own experience
is that when you actually ask in
questions and you get kind of like
speaking about them themselves actually
really enjoy it yeah I can imagine even
more so from a technical background they
actually like talking about the tech
element because there's an element of
passing on that knowledge and yeah and
sharing it right yeah so advice for
people in that market then is yet don't
feel stupid ask a question yeah and and
really listen yeah obviously right and
where's you sourcing these people I was
painting LinkedIn painting would you
like any link Tom I was sending out I'd
say 100 to 200 connect requests today
well and this was before the LinkedIn
updates when I initially joined that the
LinkedIn of the pass was so
glorious because you could put all the
filters in in terms of location and
seniority etc without needing recruiter
but now they've made recruiter such a
necessary entity that it becomes a bit
super because there's all these other
functionalities yeah it makes it
confusing so initially we just connect
requests but predominantly through
Europe European cities in engineering
specifically people want to relocate to
London because it's the tech hub of
Europe Mugabe the world people want to
be here so the idea of getting people to
relocate because London is so saturated
these candidates are bombarded every
single day mercilessly yeah so how can I
find people which aren't approached as
much through LinkedIn it was European
cities so that's what I spent most of my
time doing and was you going in the
straight for the kill here like yeah
yeah yeah yeah and the other account we
had two the one in Thailand again we
could approach any country in the world
cuz I could sponsor really I was going
through this Brazil and Ecuador and the
states and I can New Zealand every
country could think of I literally had
an alphabet of countries what I was just
going through one country per day really
was not going home until I finished the
country I said was like us then it would
take me was literally run and connect
and the literally messaging going join a
job yeah the Thailand one it was like
how effective was that believe it or not
it was really good it was effective
because of the numbers I was putting out
okay at that point it was a real numbers
game because I was new to recruitment I
didn't understand my market too well if
you like the more messages I get out the
more chances I have of getting a
response yeah the more qualification can
do the better I can understand my mom be
sent so okay at that point it was like
literally do you want to go to Thailand
and you would just find that the people
that did yeah that's fair enough
and I was it okay and then okay so then
let's just before we move on to like the
second year and so that that segment of
you've been on your own yeah Casman yeah
Bedi yeah how did I actually go then
like was it was it tough yeah so the the
guy which I was mentored by amazing
recruiter he was burned out he'd been
doing it for quite a few years
he said mental company yeah so he looked
after
basically maybe like rolls to work etc
and he just got burned out so enough is
enough and rumor has it that the his
resource or the resource there was
potentially relations going on there so
that person also decided to leave again
just rumors just rumors and when I was
on my own I inherited all of our markets
which was a combination of everything
because we were generalist at that point
okay so what happened was that the
accounts you were supposed to be
delivering against because he was coming
to the end of his career I guess in
agency recruitment he just went where
like he wasn't proactively engaging with
them I guess so the relationships there
were some which were somewhat burned and
a little bit like fragmented so going in
our healing saying like can you please
give me a chance at one point was
actually like begging clients like
please like give me a chance to prove
that I'm I'm as good as him or I can be
better than him or whatever but at that
point for most companies it was too late
and that was also when the Thailand
company said they weren't recruiting
anymore so just all came thick and fast
and I was like oh my god to the point
where I was working email developer
roles for 23 K basis it was like I need
to just put money on the board and feel
something because we just didn't have
much that was that was going on and yeah
it was just really really bizarre and I
was honestly relying on my directors to
find me roles because I'm terrible at BD
I'm awful at it even now I'm really not
very good at it really cuz I'm scared
that someone's gonna be like oh no
you're you're I've heard bad things
about break my soul so I'm the the
nicest recruit in the world when it
comes to my feelings because I think it
personally probably in the wrong job but
hey her story for a different time but
yeah it was it was just difficult
because I was always waiting for a role
to come through from someone else
because I was also trying to draw desk
as well so I was trying to do a big
contract BD and do it upon BD and a bit
of this and a bit of that and I was just
so flustered and all over the place
sounds like hell I am
I'll just wasn't billing because I was
just so Scotty my directors trying to
help me and trying to give me direction
but it was I was trapped in my own head
extent so how what did you build in your
flesh here first year
including the the initial six months I
think it was that night grande really
might 100 someone else okay yeah alright
so let let's just talk about that for a
second yeah because particularly the
beauty part even if it's now something
you deal with it such a domes right just
because the most common thing I get
asked to ask guests on the show about
his business development and you had a
similar path to me so I I sourced for
and free form um yeah my director passed
over some accounts will slowly possible
some relationships yeah and and then
when he when it went to he sham now like
let's get involved in the business
development sessions blah blah blah yeah
you all of a sudden had this really
weird relationship with the phone right
all of a sudden your yeah as you said
like you think you're going to be
rejected and all these things right yeah
so while like what why are you so scared
of it like let's just say you're in your
head and these types of things salon
they should talk about that for a second
ago there'll be people listen and they
also have that challenge and these types
of things and yeah what why was it such
a challenge for you I think it was
honestly because I was stretched so thin
and I was also trying to prove that I
deserved my job because I think when
you're in your first year most people
thrown into the deep end when it comes
to BD um at least a lot of recruiters
that I know and you're under so many so
much pressure to send out X amount of
specs and do X amount of calls and add X
amount of contacts yes erm and it's all
just a bit much and you're you're not
doing your job as well as you could
because you're trying to do so many
different things and you try to take so
many boxes and hit so many KPIs that
your brain just shuts down and and
that's why we're so terrible it because
it's like I'm trying to to find people
I'm trying to build relationships I'm
trying to learn my market and do all of
these different things which meant that
the BD piece was the thing I really
really struggled with because it was
essentially a new skill set of how do
you approach one of these these black
magical clients right how do you get
through the these guarded gates when
you're doing these cold calls how do you
get past that sodding gatekeeper who's
that
you know don't want to talk how do you
do all this it's just a completely
different mindset I guess so I I think
the the trick which I learned eventually
and thankfully the bosses will be sweet
with it was like can I please just not
add all of these freakin contacts to a
CRM that was my fingers like every time
I do a call this or this I have to log
actually everything and it was just it
was flustering is like just let me just
go I'm just gonna go message those are
people I'm not gonna track how many set
specs of San I'm gonna check everything
on the CRM just gonna see what happens
which looking back was quite brave to do
that because you don't know who you've
messaging you haven't but it was like I
just need to be free a little bit okay I
thought that makes any sense though I
think so but so we'll see you so it just
sounds like this sounds like a bit a
mixture of and you've struggled to
manage your day yeah yeah it was a lot
making sure that you're doing all the
things you need to be doing yeah and
then it seems like because the business
development part was something that you
didn't enjoy yeah you sort of just tried
to brush that under there yeah sort of
daily tasks as much as possible yeah and
then when you did do that there were
certain processes that you needed to do
which yeah you think quite enjoy um so
when you say that so okay so when you
said that you just then went freely what
do you mean by that as in like you just
just I'm literally if I sent a spec I
would not code the person I sent us back
to or why sediment basically because I
found the admin side of it so incredibly
monotonous and boring and
soul-destroying the each means you're
not enjoying a job and most importantly
it's you're not sending out as many
specs or doing as many causes you could
do if I'm to stop for two hours in my
day to code everything that I've done
it's just a nightmare
so in those four in that first year my
priority was bringing on accounts seeing
success delivering against them and
rebuilding the team so that's the
sacrifice which I chose to make and it
depends on the business you work for
whether or not you guys difficult that
one just because yeah a long-term that's
definitely not the right way no it's
nothing but nowadays I do it very
differently but back then it was like I
need to choose something yeah you just
tried it yeah that's fair enough that
I'll tell you get that that's fair
enough
um okay so year two then how long how
was it until you sort of had a few more
people around you ah sweepit are we made
some really bad hires we make some
really ribbit was involved in hire
admittedly yes so it's my bad yeah well
it wasn't it wasn't my team back line
because I wasn't senior enough but I was
taking Alka mentoring we're all we're
like I would strum the ropes a little
bit like give him advice if they needed
it but I wouldn't do one two ones or
direct line management I wouldn't give
them roles so to speak that would still
be passed on by them so the I had them
understand the path that you thought
intro them on right bit basically yeah
and we we hired this one person she
wasn't [ __ ] she was such an idiot she's
just a desk and she just about paint her
nails and stuff and just do nothing it
was just ridiculous so she didn't last
very long and then we had another dude
who still probably funniest story today
we had an interview for is a Python role
and the inci was booked in for 4:00 p.m.
he doesn't check his diary he calls up
this candidate 3:30 so how did your
interview go
kind of they starts talking yeah well
bother they've going back and forth and
this do starts closing him okay so could
you see yourself they're like yeah and
they're like yeah yeah definitely good
okay so we can't see their interviews
like yeah yeah right so he puts the
phone down right and I'm listening the
whole time I'm said a word because I
know what's coming right and I'll check
my diary because I put it in mine as
well and and this guy stands up all
excited anyone he had like two or three
years experience inside he's close he's
ready to go so I got really full of
himself testosterone pumping through his
veins chests ow I was like make great
work great work I was like but he has
interview yet so have you done that
what yeah
canceled the interview so he emailed to
cancel the interview with no client oh
my god yes so I was like you are
honestly one of the biggest idiots I've
ever met in my life there was so many
instance we did that it was we were
really struggling at one point in
engineering like really like it was with
losing the
team with me trying to rebuild it on my
own til them make 2 hires which
ultimately you just just weren't right
for the business what did you learn them
let's let's start talking about these
guys yeah what do you learn them it was
it was more about we didn't really have
seats for these people
in terms of like direct niches or an
idea of of how someone would fit in the
business for us at that time it was kind
of like panic mode it was okay how can
we just get bums on seats get people
engineering team so I'm not on my own so
I've got someone to talk to or whatever
and we learned after we hired these two
people that that was the wrong strategy
to take so from my perspective I was
much more than focused on pulling like a
volume of roles with my director today
right
let's just get some rolls with the door
let's get some accounts and it's
figuring out a niche of where we can
start carving this thing out so I was
like okay I'm going with JavaScript I'm
going with front-end so I'm going to
take care of half of the engineering
world essentially front end you got
back-end as I are going front end that's
my thing
my director was like okay I'm gonna be
coming up back into in terms of like the
BD piece yeah I'm going back end weren't
really too fussed on languages we said
we did want to work Ruby really we
didn't want about dotnet know I'm not
really Python at that time so like we're
going for like PHP roles
we're gonna go for I think it was there
was another niche down yeah so it's like
and then what we're gonna do is once
you've got a few accounts on we're gonna
go out and we're gonna find a resources
okay that many people so basically so
basically you perform the strategy
exactly and that's what we did and you
actually then tried to build a bit of a
platform exactly okay that may so when
someone comes in rather than so for
example the the god I mentioned she came
in and she didn't know what she was
doing was a party all those four right
Oh 100% yeah they made so many mistakes
in that period but it's what you learn
right exactly and with with the the two
codes previously they just kind of came
in and just were a bit sketchy uh-oh
what this or what that okay yeah it
didn't work so after that we changed
tact
we hired essentially a bulk of resources
right a few for the engineering team the
product team at that time the data team
right let's do this properly and we
focus on a strategy of getting in people
with no experience to essentially build
out that that
mid-level further so right now we had
the the lead team which was at the
directors we had the mid team which was
us guys who joined a year before and now
we wanted the juniors so then grow into
the mid position and after we did that
we we haven't looked back and that's
when we started really expanding and I'm
putting some money on the board
yeah nice that's okay that's really
interesting so and that whole process
then happened in year two yeah India -
yeah yeah okay
cool how do you how did you get on year
two then yeah UT was good
so Billings wise did just shy of two
5000 which I was really happy with that
we don't go [ __ ] [ __ ] pretty decent
yeah honestly the second year when we
nailed down what we wanted to do it was
honestly just taking a bit of a step
back saying what do we want to do here
like what what direction we going in and
more importantly how do we want to
structure this business so this meeting
was across the whole team like how do we
want to go out all of our teams that's
great and that was the most value
experience I think I've had to date to
say okay what do we want the long-term
of this business to look like we've came
up with like three year plans of how
we're going to scale blah blah blah
which is all well and good but it was
looking at the the next 12 months who
took a step they took a step that and
that was it so we're like right we're
gonna hire a few resources in in Jam I'm
gonna hire a few resources in in July
cuz that's what people and then we'll
look again in Jan as well so so coming
up with dedicated hiring cycles rather
than sporadically hiring a throughout
the year and being reactive okay
okay that's just very quickly you're
broken down that really well but that's
that's a quite big job yeah around circa
hundred Kmart yeah second year 250 yeah
how did you achieve that them with
clearly some failures along the way
these sorts of things like how did you
like talk to me a bit about how you how
yeah how you managed to increase those
Billings yeah would you put that down
too so besides from from getting a
higher interest you right
it came down to a change in in my Biddy
strategy okay talk to because in in my
first year it was very much you do Bedi
by calling through a list or by
journaling through a list or use
one of these tools to find jobs or leads
whatever or dragging leads from your
candidates for me I'm not very good at
that
that's not my strong suit my strong suit
is talking to people understanding my
market and really just building
long-term relationships yeah when I have
one of my candidates in process I make
sure that they are treated like a king
or queen okay as best as physically
possible it's not possible with everyone
because some people were just a bit
strange but again story for a different
time and rather than go through all
these other ways of doing BD I just went
simple and that was all of these people
that I'm placing why wouldn't I just
keep in contact with them why wouldn't
you say hey you wanna grab a beer
it was literally as simple as that of
just keeping those relationships going
and that meant that I was pulling rolls
through clients that they had joined
through clients they knew were we're
recruiting through friends through
networks it all came through referrals
and recommendations and I know that
sounds a little bit cliche like I get
all of my roles through recommendations
but genuinely in my second year that's
the strategy where I took so the
strategy is double down on your kind of
their relationship yes okay and when you
say that you mean obviously building
that relationship yeah but and then are
you pretty much basically asking these
people saying who's the hiring manager
hi there hi ring and then these people
would then go look I know you're hiring
yeah I know this guy reads very good or
whatever it was that is literally can
you insure me via email and even if it
leads to nothing what you would find is
if they didn't want to work it initially
in three six months they so hadn't seen
their success or they've got a new rule
about just thinking if you get intros
and on the other no whatever a front end
yeah engineer whatever right yeah and I
intro my hiring manager to recently oh
my hang on a minute this work really
speaking to my talent do you know I mean
well this this is where you have to be
quite delicate with the what the intro
actually yes I mean so I always use a
pretty structured format in terms of
these intro emails looks out to be
give me the pretty careful
was literally I've worked with rece in
the past before I joined this business
okay
first and foremost second of all it
would be we still keep in contact he's
not trying to poach me he's just a good
guy speak to him to yourself and you'll
see what I mean
so I'm called that solid that's what I
mean that sort of I was all I was quite
worried about that first admittedly but
the more that you do it the more
recommendations you get because it's
such a small community the
recommendations just kind of if they
hear it from one person they'll also
check it with someone else
yeah so for me again the personal
branding piece is so freaking important
so like my recommendations and LinkedIn
are trying it as many as physically
possible so that way if I've had an
intro via email you're gone LinkedIn and
say oh he's worked with sew ins yeah so
it just had to be quite consistent in
the way that we when you switch to a
strategy like this you need to make sure
your brand is on point and that your
recommendations can come from a number
of different places essentially so that
way there's consistency across the
market what's in it for the candidate to
be honest with you just a lot of love
and affection yeah that's the way which
I always phrase it it's a case of if if
you can intro me I will take you out on
a lovely evening of the book Sheree or
whatever you want to do I've had some
very weird requests of how we want to do
it others are more set on taking like a
percentage of the fee which again fine
with if they want really they want to
take a small percentage as a cut more
than happens you don't know yeah
multiple times so that's really
interesting for me like it but luckily
with bosses are happy to do it which is
awesome because it's like if I can say
for example say right temp sent the fee
we're gonna give to you as a thank you
so let's say it's a grand and you get a
grand the business is made I love them
it makes commercial sense and if they do
it again and then again and again so the
idea is particularly with contract
talent as well is if you shout these
relationships they do your BD for you
they're like your little pigeons they
just fly off and they just they get the
the word about few and far out there and
it's just doing something like that
which is so small that can just be so
powerful so it just usually means that
when we're negotiating terms of
businesses we try and get and
percent or two just to kind of
accommodate we are going to be losing
okay that's that's interested in so for
you
the big reason then for you to sort of
leveling up your buildings and stuff was
getting the BD approach yeah right so
I'm assuming then this meant that yeah
you had way more opportunity to make
more money yeah and these types of
things so would you sit bait and then
you back yourself to the deliver and
gems of really resourcing definitely
yeah yeah cuz I mean everyone will say
it's a kind of a short market in your
world right yeah yeah but I think you
mentioned it you mentioned it briefly
there how are you is there any on the
sort of resourcing and delivering side
anything that you did really well that
you feel contributed to you hitting that
sort of 250 month because I've seen you
guys online the new talk about building
communities and all these sorts of
things right yeah did was this happening
in year two did that did that impact the
the sort of Billings amount in terms of
because you spoke about the BD strategy
Ben okay what did you do differently on
the inside that impacted that resourcing
side not too much I think it was more a
touch on earlier thought I would I focus
on a specific market okay so the niche
and the focus yeah it was rather than me
do all of these other types of different
roles like email developers and cloud
veneers or whatever so so it was because
you was focusing on that yeah every job
that you worked met there was then the
backlog of people that maybe didn't fit
that that you could then use okay okay
and you're free so so you've been here
free and uh but three enough is four
half years okay cool you're free then
yeah
what when linear free did you level up
your billing so technically says I guess
still my third year until the end of
December I think something like that
okay but from because I joined in July
it was a little bit awkward but but
today so this year there's lots really
too much difference in my third year and
now to be fair so this year we've done
two sixty to date so far so uh I want to
do more ideally but our targets four
hundred this year so with what would you
say when we there yeah so this is the
team hello if you other so there's now
for us and you manage that team yeah and
then when you so then you're billions
and
these people contribute to that figure
it depends on the role that they fill so
if when they initially join if they join
as a resource or experience that will
solely go to my Billings if they get
promoted that's when we start doing it
dividing play essentially so we'll do
splits for example so we have 25% fur
for each section of the process so
account management pulling the role
finding the candidate managing the candy
ok it depends on on what level you do as
to what split you get so there are deals
where I'll get 0 and it won't go towards
out that 260 and there will be deals
where I get 75% ok so yeah when did you
start managing people in my second year
I took on my first person which didn't
work out which was a shame I wasn't
supposed to manage that person but my
boss who was supposed to manage this
person broke his collarbone and was out
of all of the office for I think about
two months or something so yeah wasn't
in place
it was literally can you look after her
because she doesn't have anyone else to
learn from so rather than just mentor
her attitude directly lead everything
and and yeah it didn't work out she did
two placements in I think 9 months or
something and she realized she didn't
want to do the job and she's now a
primary school teacher so yeah that was
the first experience and after that
started really like kicking off on
management from July last year so took
on the first person then and since then
added another yeah three people to the
team
what okay what let's just focus on that
for a second yeah clearly had a lot of
failures yeah was this sort of mentoring
manager and whatever you want to call
that yeah what have you got right this
time structure yeah you seem pretty oh
man yeah
how how how was structure enabled you to
be a better manager and build this team
so we we reached out to um to an
external guy to come in and help us in
leadership training which at first I was
really skeptical about the idea of
having an experienced recruiter comment
and tell you how to do your job I got
my backup really badly first time I met
this guy I was just like whatever
and we started doing the training
sessions with him so we take out half a
day a month to go with him and he would
just talk us through the challenges he's
faced etc and he introduced a management
framework to us which but very very
simply was just a process we would
follow in terms of sitting down with
your team the stuff you would cover the
targets you would set and the
conversations which you would have and
most importantly is asking them what
freaking motivates them because none of
us had done that one of us before when
we were mentoring had said so what
motivates you it's such a simple
question and none of us had thought
about it we've never had a conversation
with anyone we'd ever taken on including
other exes to us saying guys what
motivates you like what gets shot a bed
where do you want to be in three years
or five years and it was that shifting
dynamic of adding in those processes
understanding wider motivations that we
could genuinely drill in on the the
structure and and performance of the the
team right so nowadays with with the
guys I've got right now every day we do
this the same thing we sit down at the
same time as we cover the the same
topics and we see success from it
because everyone knows what to expect
whereas before we would common in the
morning but honestly we come in the
morning you know what you doing today
yeah I do cool done no that was my
morning catch-up and I would be done for
the rest of the day well and it we get
to Friday and they would have to CBS out
and I say what the hell have you been
doing all week yeah okay that's a shitty
manager yeah yeah definitely okay if I'm
listening right now haven't got much
process how I'm gone my structure what
what should I like from from that how
price that you've gone through now yeah
what should be the first thing that I
should implement and do and that will
probably have the biggest impact if you
think in terms of management oh yeah in
terms of management management so that
when you take on people in your team the
the most frustrating thing I would say
and the easiest mistake to slip into is
answering questions so if I'm so at my
desk and when I resources has a question
for me I will instantly want to answer
I will instantly want to help them and I
think it's the worst mistake that you
can do okay so the reason why I say that
is because you need to have dedicated
times where you have conversations with
your team if you get questions thrown at
you sporadically throughout the day it
screws up your day plan it distracts you
more importantly it doesn't allow them
to figure out themselves so we can slip
down this rabbit hole of babying okay so
slightly so just giving that autonomy to
just let them crack on and do their
stuff and the rule is like it can you
find the answer by googling it if you
can we'll have a conversation in our
catch-up right unless it's life or death
unless you're telling me the candidate
is dropped out of the final interview
which is taking place in 30 minutes cool
that's fine
perfectly okay is my boolean correct do
we need to have a conversation at 10:30
in the morning no because we've had a
catch up at 8:30 or 9:00 we don't need
to have another catch up in an hour's
time unless it sort of been booked in so
just sticking to that that solid
structure makes so much difference
because it means that you can do your
job and if you can do your job you can
pull roles for these guys you can find
candidates for so what's the structure
then the structure so you have three
catch-up today you have one long one in
the morning once you're in but long long
one usually 45 minutes you sit there
you'll run through each of their day
plans your annual set smart target right
cool not like cool KPI is like oh you
need to have 20 pre-screens by the end
of the day or something wave like that
but saying if you're going through
recruiter okay how many people join a
message in that time okay on a message
30 people cool so between 10 and 12 you
know message 30 people on LinkedIn
recruiter awesome cool it's measurable
we can we can work with that yeah do
that for the whole team what do you guys
want to do what roles you focusing on
why do you think that's the right role
to focus on let's talk through it as a
team after that we just set them off
into the world you guys do their thing
they crack on lunch time literally 10
minutes guys how you getting on do you
need any help what questions have you
got etc having that just general touch
point do you need anything
most of the time it's it's a no or a
Sukkah generic question end of the day
again
10-15 minutes how does your day go do
you need any help if they said yeah I
haven't had time to do this call you're
staying late right if you haven't
finished what you need
do stay late and crack on most the time
we don't need to sit okay and then just
and then like that and then if they try
and grab you
between that ten and twelve when you've
decided what they're focusing on or
whatever is it you say no well that like
you decide if that can wait or whatever
yeah yeah all I say is is it
life-threatening
is it life-threatening no it's not okay
let's have a catch-up Porteous trip with
that yeah and draw at first you feel
like a dick for doing yeah no but that's
but honestly the thing for me is like
you need to give people autonomy to
crack on and do this yeah and if you
just constantly baby them and say this
is the answer this is the answer this
then they can't progress so and then the
final important on that yeah
if right now I'm a manager listening to
have a small team or whatever or even is
it I guess it's beneficial as as an
individual because you said that yeah
you having done it for yourself and
what's like how did you then cultivate
or what's the conversation to understand
why these what these people motivated by
like how does that go and walk how can
people approach that apart from asking
that the question of what motivates you
because everyone I see with yeah some
people will say money inevitably some
people have some sort of answer like
progressing which is a bit generic yeah
the question which we were taught to ask
is you ask your team when was the last
time you felt motivated online and
they'll say so when my boss did this to
me I think is I knew what he was gonna
ask me because I was in the same
training session I know what you were
doing it pal as it's in the last time I
was motivate was when we had the Vegas
incentive because I've never been
outside of Europe Vegas like I've heard
horrible horrible things about this
place I want to go there yeah yeah that
was a real time and we dug into it and
one of my key motivations was making
memories really weird right now and they
said now if my boss wants something from
me he'll try and spin something but it
will be a memory like yeah even like
they're stitching me up lace by dressing
me up because I've lost a bet with one
of them right no I was like if it'll be
a memory
so that's a really good point you made
hair is like once once you then tapped
into it
you dug deeper then yeah I just wanna
progress yeah I want to make money right
yeah then all of a sudden you have a
real enabler and fuel to go yeah if I'm
working for you and you know my
motivators make memories or whatever
yeah you go Reese yeah honestly you like
it's remember we said that you serious
about buying that property for your
family or whatever light is that do you
know I mean use that yeah okay cool
that's interesting I think the the
easiest mistake to make though is is
relying on the money motivator because
recruitment right it's not the best job
in the world as we all know it can be
really horrible and we're all sold that
money is the reason why we do this but I
think you need to dig into why money is
important so even if it is I really want
to buy a house for my mum why it's
getting that next level next what most
people stop there and be like oh cool so
remember buy the house here mum but why
do you want to buy the house for them on
like what's going on underneath it and
that's when it gets really interesting
and that's when you can really work with
your team because if you understand your
team you know how to get the best out of
them but again when I first started
managing and I've only been doing it for
a year so I don't want to preach like I
know everything because trust me I don't
definitely the the first time I was just
like do more deals you're poor you're on
20k or you're struggling right you need
food okay bit of a segue them okay cool
so what Warren to ask you about then
which I think will be really interesting
so few and far yes I went to your launch
party the other week which is good fun
yeah and you've had some interesting
experience right so in a nutshell when
did you do the offering where you went
on site for one of your clients was that
in the third year was the end of the
yeah second year and the second year it
was in the second year bigger than the
third year yeah essentially a little bit
before the third year no so it's more
like the middle of second year to end
the second year so it's like a six month
period so so this was really interesting
because I think most people listening to
understand there's been over
shifting recruitment recently in terms
of the models that are being offered
mm-hmm there is the growth of this
on-site model which has been sold as the
the be-all-end-all
every recruiter and every recruitment
company is now exploring the possibility
of going on site with their clients
right which you know it could be a great
thing it could be a bad thing depending
on the business but we're in a position
where I think we were trying to be
reactive we were looking at other
businesses and their success and the
clients they were winning and their
marketing we're like wow we could do
that but better so that's what we're
gonna do and that's when we tested it
with with rush partners and at the time
we were planning on hiring someone
permanently for us who we would
essentially contract out like a
consultancy model and we we looked for a
few months and we just couldn't find
anyone who who we liked so my boss
turned around to me one day and said hey
how would you feel about doing this and
at first I was like no I'm all right
thanks mate
and the more you explained the reasons
why we were doing it and the fact it was
like a pilot scheme he sold me
completely yeah and you know I'm really
glad that he did because it was probably
one of my best experiences today so okay
we literally went on site with these
guys
and we we looked at the whole offering
it was we reviewed their benefits
package we reviewed their their specs we
reviewed their their marketing strategy
for them in terms of attracting talent
we reviewed their hiring process
reviewed their sourcing strategies their
ATS is everything down to the last like
freaking point yeah right honestly it
was amazing okay
why isn't because you have so much
control over the the process and and you
know what to expect so rather than send
a CV and it just kind of goes off into
to this other world like this black hole
vision Yasim with this you would send
the CV to yourself and you would do the
screening calls yourself and when you're
handing over the CVS you can look at
your hiring managers and say right this
is what we've discussed this is what
this person has said that they're
they're stronger this is my concern
about the candidate do you want to call
and you have so much more
roll not just over the client but but
over the process and over almost like
you're your own screenings because you
know what the client wants because
you're sat next to them so why is that
beneficial because that way you know
exactly what you're looking for and you
can actually get hires through the door
whereas most the time we as recruiters
have like one qualification call you
know give me five points that can get
this person the first interview and then
we'll just kind of go through the
process and then that's it yeah and I I
don't know about anyone else but I I get
a lot of rejections for culture fit
technical skills most people you either
have it what you doing is sure it's a
cotton culture fit was the key thing but
when you're on site with these guys how
did I actually was like where's you
start who you said with yeah they gave
me a desk really yeah it's at next to
the CTO um and yeah that was it but the
the the scary thing about it is if
you're not doing your job properly
you're not just answering to your boss
your agents yeah different you are
directly answering to the CTO who sat
right next to you yeah he won't say to
you okay so how many people you message
today right and it's not like agency was
like I haven't done as many as I should
have sorry boss yeah if you haven't
asked me then like why are we paying you
why are we using back then no I we doing
that so the added pressure of delivering
was was ridiculous and I'm assuming you
was like the added element of you being
on site there's also a bigger driver of
to definitely to help because like you
yeah you'll see the real impact there
yeah in your face yeah honestly it was
if I don't deliver here we're going to
get fired
and our pilot run is a failure because
of me and all that pressure I was like
that's awesome let's do it this and all
you did all day was sauce yeah well
asides from all the initial restrain
yeah but that also took quite a lot of
time okay then when we set it up we were
always adjusting it in all sense he's
always catching up I understand it has
anything changed we need to really
review exact technical okay cool and
then just quit one then how like that
whole overall experience yes how did it
then what was the result
we made 12 or 13 placements so
things like a four month period okay
that was everyone was an engineer apart
from one and that was a UX guy and yeah
it was it was very very successful right
um what what would you say was the
biggest and benefit to the client for
doing that they didn't have to do
anything really that I would take care
of everything for them like I said the
the strategy piece the the benefits
review everything I would give them
recommendation so rather than going out
and doing them research we would present
all the data to them saying look this is
what your competitors are doing this is
how we can do it better so we did all of
the the data piece for them so let's do
was just essentially press the green
button to say go so okay and then how
how was your overall experience to that
because I'm thinking like how often and
was she there I was there once a week
sometimes twice just once a week and
then the rest of the time you was in the
office in this office yeah okay how was
that experience towards the end it
burned me out really badly Pro don't
leak cause of the commute though because
I live toward Stratford and the the guys
at Russia based in Paddington so I was
doing about an hour and 10 on that one
day well I would go in it was just like
I'm commuting it was just
it sucked but that was also because
towards the end of the ten year this is
when we had sat down and done a hiring
strategy and said this is what we want
to recruit for cetera so trying to do
the recruitment on on our side in terms
of internally to find resources etc and
manage against other clients and deliver
against other clients it was so much to
take on the after four months as my boss
and said look as much as I'm loving it
we need to find a replacement so we did
find a replacement for me which all the
contract recruited to go in there and he
did an awesome job as well okay
that's really interesting and okay and
then um what what the other thing I
wanted to make sure that we covered was
cuz I think you guys really push this
yeah and I don't know if you've been
involved in some of the events that I've
seen or whatever yeah that you guys
really preach around building
communities yeah
for me what does actually mean building
communities is not just about sending
one cv or making one placement or two
placement or even three
it's about genuinely that building
relationships for the long term so well
like I said earlier it might be D
strategy was reaching out to previous
candidates I'd worked with for me I have
now my own engineering community of
people that I can reach out to and have
a great relationship with on top of that
we are also really really hot on the
meetup side so actually going to events
hosting events partnering with events
and mostly paying for pizza and booze
because that's the way to everyone's
heart admittedly so we've been working
with mine the product now for for years
and years and years we work with UX
crunching you next and we run around
hackathon it's doing all these other
things which are giving back to the
wider community I guess so it's all
about those long-term relationships and
sustaining them but in terms of the new
model offering what you're looking at
its are you saying look if you want to
go and recruit twenty people at one time
we'll take care of it that's not a
problem or if you want to recruit one
person at a time over a three-year
period which is going to lead to 20
hires we'll cover you and it's just a
girl coming up with different service
offerings where we can accommodate that
yeah okay yeah on the communities piece
because are a lot of people particularly
in the tech market to be fair have spoke
about events right yeah how does that
make you more money so from the most
obvious one is from a BD piece when you
say I run my own hackathon it makes you
sound quite unique is this an obvious
one so you're you're more likely to pull
clients yeah if you say you know I am
problem about jobs not really no it's
usually just saying are asking them
about what the hell's going on and just
introducing yourself saying yeah well
you know we saw that there's for example
a react Meetup attending the guys down
like what you're thinking or with the
hackathon it's do you guys want to
compete you want to come down bring the
team there's no entry fee all like weird
terms attached to it it's just I'll let
you want to come down and just do some
awesome shiva cherry in terms of the
mind the product piece so going on stage
and introducing yourself to
I think like a thousand product managers
know what I'm saying hey if you need a
job you need advice on your CV if you
ever want about your your career
trajectory
career trajectory yeah that's a hard
word then come to us if you ever looking
for managers again come to us it's being
the official recruitment partner for
these huge platforms where if someone
gets made redundant god forbid then they
think okay who do I know who do I know
who don't know so
oh what's that meet up and there was
those yeah okay I reach out to them and
you'd be surprised at how many
candidates we get from that really so
yeah it's definitely okay every penny
just to wrap that up have you have you
been involved at all in like the start
of starting these events well I'm sure
there being multiple people involved
yeah if I'm listening right now had
three or four people now talk about
events or whatever was what sort of your
advice to start and where do they come
from and how do you approach it so I was
one of the the following guys of the
hockey game to the hackathon that we run
alongside the the guy that used to work
here okay and the marketing team and
we've really had still love research
into what was already on the market okay
so what what had already been done
and could it be done differently /
better so with the higher games
there are lots and lots of hackathons
yeah lots of hackathons most of which
are internal or maybe there'll be one or
two companies compete against each other
but there's never been one that's been
done across multiple of different
companies across different like sectors
and all this different stuff so and I
last like a thon we had like a sauce
versus just eat versus moon pig versus
the guy's a judo peso analysis a
start-up where 12 different types of
businesses who they have no business
going against each other though they've
got no reason to clash before a
different hackathon so putting on
clients against each other to see who
was the best was something which had
never been done before
okay so it was just the the the thing I
would always recommend avoiding
especially in our space is everyone
thinks the answer is to found their own
meetup yeah I'm gonna host
Scala Meetup I'm gonna do a job it's
been done time and time and time and
time again if you want to partner with
one that's very successful again you
have to ask yourself from a business
perspective what is my return on my
investment yeah how can we do things
differently when we're actually at the
meet-up are we just gonna go and turn up
with with free pizzas or can I have a
store where I do career coaching can I
say look guys you don't have to be
looking for a job but if you want to
come over and talk to me about your
career or how you should have a
conversation with your boss about your
salary of you or whatever use us as
those guys right that that's it so it's
just about thinking from things from a
different perspective how you can add
value genuinely how can I add value but
do it in a way that isn't done
constantly if you are one of these
people that found your own meetup or
partner to the meetup and you stand
awkwardly on the side and you just
occasionally just grunt at people like
you're not gonna get anything from that
yeah so okay interested in um okay mate
three last things before we finish just
because um be keen to get your thoughts
and also just thinking of the things
that people will ask me quite a lot
recently yeah until free things so the
first thing I think just to round up
your whole experience and journey with
this business development piece and life
you've already spoke a bit about how you
approach it differently yeah
but I've had quite a few messages
recently as how like could you talk to
people about how they've approached it
in a really different and unique way
yeah so you've already mentioned about
candidates you've already mentioned
about the events yeah is it anything
else just cuz I feel like you'd be quite
open to it like you've used you've done
creatively or out of the box to try and
grab people's attention from a business
development standpoint I I have and I
still do one thing in my specs
I attach a meme a meme I mean well okay
I'm telling you dude it works really you
send them it you can't choose an
offensive one okay I've made the senior
specs so when I'm sending an email
through of saying hey yes while you're
recruiting for us I've got this one
person in mine like a brief
overview whatever usually the structure
I don't get all these needles all the
time so if you don't respond here's a
meme which will hopefully make you laugh
nice I like okay done great answer I
love that okay cool and really like that
answer that's wicked next one and a few
people asked me about this recently so I
asked the last chap this counteroffers
yeah it's such a locker typical it's
such a cool like ya know the answer that
sent the people when they accepted can
refer don't last whatever yeah but I had
a few people recently message about he
sure would love you to sorts of people
about counteroffers or whatever in like
what's like your if one of your guys
right now and they're candidates
acceptable to account or for whatever
what's your advice for these people
what's your like goatee lines it depends
on what stage the the thing I would
always say is you have to cover your
counteroffer in a very very first call
and if you don't do it there or you
don't do it properly you're always going
to be susceptible yeah so I'll answer in
a few different ways first and foremost
in that conversation you have the very
first conversation
most people say what if they gave you an
extra 10 K or something like have you
made up your mind about leaving the
business does your boss know something
like that the question is which we asked
or what can your company do to keep you
in that exact way right what can they do
and they say nothing no that's not
that's not one of the answers you can
give what can they do they can fire the
CEO and the CT and the CPA corpus not
gonna happen so I don't think you're
susceptible to a counselor okay okay if
they say oh they'd have to give me an
extra 30 grand okay why what about that
30 grand would make you happy I just
feel valued in my job okay so money is
the only way you can feel valuable yeah
okay but the role that I've got in mind
for you is only an extra 5 K so how does
that work
oh well money isn't everything okay but
you just said it's everything you really
get under the bonnet yeah understanding
from that very first call and most the
time you say have you had a conversation
manager but I think you need to make a
decision as to whether or not it's
realistic for something to happen or
this counteroffer to happen so for
example I've had one
councillor off at my career it was in my
third month it broke my heart because
the guy had accepted the offer he said
let's go in grab a beer so I turn up I'm
buzzing oh I've just banged in a deal
this is my promotion I think back in the
day and I was like yes and the office
like we were all buzzing well duh
Maurice you've done your promotion deal
is like number six or something and I
turn up and it's guys that much great
would be with you because I've accepted
a counteroffer I don't see let you know
that there was no hard feelings
and I sat there the whole meeting
heartbroken oh my god I said but but how
was I you told me they'd have to retrain
you in a different technology and I'd
have to give you at least 15k there's no
way they'd do both so it did was it how
and he walked me through it is that
because the the their product
essentially was still quite early stage
so they could take different technical
decisions so because he said he was
leaving and they loved him so much he
sat down with the CTO and he was like
okay let's change so they switched from
PHP to node that's like doesn't make
sense but that for me is because I
should have realized in a small business
that's possible it's uncommon so I will
inevitably have a counteroffer at one
stage in my career in the next I don't
know six months a year 18 months where I
should have seen it coming but I didn't
write because counteroffers as much as
Rick who just think they have control
over everything sometimes they don't
most of the time accounts are off as we
do yeah there's gonna be tons on you
combat to assess the realistic Ness of
their answer of what can they do to what
kind of disco yeah that's where you go
and you need to get them to give you an
answer nothing nothing okay why is it
nothing because I hate it here they're
all are told I hate them they're enough
that's good advice mate and lost two
things and I think obviously you've been
on a quite interesting journey clearly
being plenty of chaos yeah
failures yeah and cleared that like done
well what what what's enable you to get
through some of the that that chaos and
the this or resilience piece right yeah
I'd be keen to get your thoughts on this
line when you when you fall about
quitting when you've had these really
bad
failures like what how have you sort of
pulled for the other side and now
clearly in a good spot and yeah also you
can always improve and stuff there yeah
there there are two things the first one
sounds like a bit of a weed cringe
answer but it's true
and that's the trust which which my
bosses have given me the the guys that
they run few and far is the very first
business they've never done it before
which means they make mistakes but they
also allow us to make mistakes and
there's managers like I've spoken on
this podcast I've made a few as a
manager right or even generally and
they've always just let all of us crack
on there's no one behind me threatening
me with the lose your job or you haven't
hit your core kpi's or be on the phone
long enough it's none of that it's
you're given full trust to crack on
which means if I'm going through a [ __ ]
time it's probably my fault because
they've given me the autonomy to do what
I think is best so then I can sit there
and go okay can I change it can I do
something different what am I doing
wrong
so rather than blame someone else
because I think in some people that
we've hired from other businesses they
follow up the boss or the type
environment or whatever in this business
it's genuinely not like that so it means
if I walk away from from recruitment I
have failed
it's on me I have screwed up that's the
first one more importantly though is the
culture that we operate within and I
think this is a true of every single
recruitment business if you enjoy where
you work and the people that you work
with recruitment becomes much much
easier yeah luckily I work with some
freaking animals
yeah where we can go out we can have a
good time we go go-karting together or
we're planning a trip to Butlins
together at the moment which is very
bizarre yeah but if you're friends with
the people that you work with and you
pull yourself up and your working
environment where for example we have a
quarterly night out what we go to
Weatherspoon's alright sounds sounds
terrible right but one of my bosses hate
it with a passion because he thinks
Wetherspoons is just full of scum yeah
yeah but it's it's just weird and
different so having a team to pick you
up when you're down and also you being
in there to pick up other people and
bounce
off each other and I'm giving each other
different ideas and I'm really just
finding a place where you have some
friends one of the the things which
someone said to me a long time ago was
that you you have your your personal
life and you have your professional life
and you keep them separate for me we do
not do that if someone want to join this
business and they wanted a clear
distinction between work and impersonal
a wouldn't work realistically because we
are friends
what are you doing the weekend it's
watch some Netflix we will talk about
what of a horror stories yeah if one of
the guys have been on a horrible day I
mean cats are just bit bit sort of being
in this top of the ramen has really
helped you yeah because you like I said
the most important thing is that you can
have friends around you yes you're not
working for people which is showing at
you saying your failure you've not done
kpi's whatever well I I go for beers
constantly with my directors and we've
seen them both in horrible states
horrible states well yeah I think I
think well I think well you're what
you're also saying they're just sort
write that up is that um even though yet
it would it it was you the made a
failure and it found it really difficult
whatever I've been in that top of
Ireland burn those types of
relationships it becomes like not just
about you definitely it you know I mean
it's all of a sudden it's like yeah
you're thinking about other people that
can help you get through yeah a tough
time it's not just you and these lots of
things right yeah no and we talked about
like building communities for our
clients and stuff but you have to
practice what you preach yeah
if we can't do it internally and we
can't set up for example the best ways
of attracting our own talent ourselves
how the hell can we advise anyone else
we'd be like that's right last two
questions first one what what has been
the well it's been the the best reason
and I can ask you for them not sure not
to an interview
I've had that my dad's died a lot really
a lot like I probably get it once every
six weeks honor it's always the dad
always there sometimes my mom's in
hospital but you know what the I have a
better interview story which was with it
was a Google Hangouts interview yeah
where it was a video call I'm really
clear to the candidate was like dude
it's a video call make sure there's
nothing weird behind you sure you're
closed most importantly yeah I don't
know almost see nipples on on hangouts
like this is a job pain that 80 grand
yeah yeah sure I've got this I've got
this any two starts and I've got this
kind of slack and the kind of messages
me what's in she's going on it's like um
can I show you something and I was like
sure what's going on and a guy sends me
a screenshot over the vehicle and the
screenshot swear to god I'll show you
after the two this right was there was
someone asleep behind him right as in
passed out it looked like a dead body
so this side the whole time the the
carrot was facing for looking in the the
the screen and there was a woman led
behind him not moving just completely
and so it just unconscious
like dead oh my god and the climate zone
goes it's cheap all right you are doable
she's my cleaner what are you doing so
at that point you say oh I don't think
he'll be right for the role and hung up
and he messed up II was like that for
future Ikki gave me such a balling for
it was like can you make sure the Canada
is prepared I was like I said make sure
that there's nothing behind you or
you're clothed and I said what did you
do that well technically nothing was
behind me there's a person behind you
assume and before finish then what were
you excited about mate what's going on
at a few and far
whew and Phil's going on there's the
sexy name and on honestly man I think
recruitment is becoming more and more
and more and more saturated and I think
everyone you have on the podcast will
say something similar with with us I'm
genuinely excited because now we're in a
position where all of us are getting
more experience Nick and Sam will be
running the business South for quite a
few years they've kind of been never
done it they've seen that the good times
and the bad times with us as managers
we've made really horrible mistakes like
we've discussed today well they're
clients as well with BD we've had some
some very bad failures we've had people
were sleeping in to use like we've just
discussed and we've been learning from
those mistakes constantly so we're now
in a position where we can do something
freaking awesome and before of having
the brand that we did where our logo was
a bull's-eye and our name was know it
which is probably the most arrogant name
I've ever heard ever from any recurrent
business I've seen and now we've we've
really looked at everything we've
learned from our internal stuff as well
as the research we've done from our
clients and when we did a race about God
name they said it was [ __ ] was the
words we use which is an idea and
because we've been taking those steps
and doing the research we have and like
I said making sure we're not repeating
them a section in the past we're now in
a position where the team is growing
where we're putting money in the board
and we're all having fun so we're in a
position where honestly we can do so
much here and we can have a real impact
in this market if we carry on with what
we're doing now so there are so many
awesome other companies out there doing
some great things but for us we just
want our name to be included in that
bracket so when you think of the the
best IT recruitment company or
recruitment agencies we want ours to be
the number one or one of the first ones
you think of yeah and if we can do that
with our market presence with you know
the the events that we run all the the
people we partner with all the
experiences we give candidates honestly
we can do so much and genuinely stop
being referred to as as as recruiters as
chaucer's yeah if I'm on right now I
don't want to
to see people walk away from me when I
say I'm a recruiter because it happens
all the time
yeah I think that using excuse because
my face needs some work
i I want I'm never ever gonna change the
perception of recruitment we're never
ever going to do that but if we can
change for search and recruitment in our
market and even we say there are a few
good companies out there because right
now we have just such our IT recurrent
business have such a horrible reputation
across the board yeah if we can break
from that niche and be like damn these
guys are actually pretty good hmm
even if it's with other business like
I've said we're in a really good place
my ultimate goal is to shut down as many
IT recruitment departments as possible
obviously
yes but are we going to do that maybe
not so can we just be known for being
good at what we do yes so yeah there's a
lot of stuff planned where we're doing
some cool [ __ ] but I guess we'll see
what happens including that last
question
mm-hmm if you could communicate to
everyone listening right now and anyone
in recruitment they take on your advice
yeah they'd implement reese's advice
tomorrow it could be a word of phrase
yeah what would you say to these people
learn your market learn your freakin
market if you can so what we touched on
earlier is don't be afraid to ask stupid
questions and this applies to any
industry don't feel like an idiot
because your manager sat right next to
you or your boss essentially or whatever
it is or that you think the candidates
gonna think that you don't know your
market it's fine to not know the answers
to everything about your market because
if you did know what the answers you
would be recruiting yourself right if I
knew everything about microservices
architecture I wouldn't be a recruiter
I'd be some 90 grand and I would be a
back-end developer but I don't want to
do that so don't be afraid to just learn
a little bit about what you do is that
that's the the biggest thing and that's
when I first joined I was scared at
first and I realized that I was being
really really dumb so it's been a
pleasure mate thank you